[Music]  there's a struggle going on in the UK  now at home about whether you should be  allowed to come home or not you know  that  what is what are your feelings about  that I think a lot of people should have  like sympathy towards me for everything  I've been through you know and I all  right I didn't know why I was going into  and I left and I just was hoping that  maybe it could stick with me and my  child let me come back I can't live in  this camper over the head of the foreign  intelligence services in the UK says  people like you are potentially very  dangerous what would you say to him they  don't have any evidence against me doing  anything dangerous when I went to Syria  I was just house wife and I for years  stayed home to care about him to care of  my kids I never did anything dangerous  and I'm a punk and I never encouraged  people become serious or it only  approved I did anything those dangerous